for some families it's a lifeline I've
got my son back and that's the biggest
thing and the ultimate in bespoke
learning having the ability to be able
to do what I want to is but as home
education becomes more popular we'll
look at what happens when it goes wrong
it was actually being a natural you know
what what my peers would have gained
from education and meet the homemade
parents fighting back against the threat
of tighter rules I just chose to do what
I'm allowed to do legally which is to
educate my child otherwise in Walsall
the Wonka family turned to home
education when they felt mainstream
school had failed them problems in
secondary school had left
twelve-year-old J anxious and depressed
and he started lashing out in class he
was heading for permanent exclusion home
educating him was the only for me the
only option I was really nervous about
all day every day oh my god
but once I started connecting with the
groups that are available and access I
didn't realize it just was a whole new
world and that opened up the walkers a
part of a growing movement home
education numbers have increased 78
percent over the past five years there's
an estimated 45,000 home educated
children religion and culture are given
as the main reasons for taking kids out
of school but a growing number of
parents are doing it to avoid their
children being permanently excluded for
the walkers a decision made in
desperation is working it's really fun
it's actually more enjoying than school
you could actually wake up at like 11:00
he's there waking up to 6 o'clock in the
morning and you can go through lessons
whenever by law a parent must ensure a
child is educated to suit their age and
ability but the rest is flexible with no
set curriculum or exams or wakeup times
plums really waiting for you in South
London Samia Toshio holds a weekly
homemade lesson for her son and other
local homemade children
it's run by a private tutor the parents
share the cost and in the next-door room
their concerns the alternative nature of
home education has made it a target with
parents perceived as different and
children weird people seem to be very
concerned about socializing well I don't
know any home educated child who isn't
socialized told me they're all very
socialized there are so many groups and
networks and things going on for kids
these two now to access higher education
many homemade children will take GCSE in
a-levels but the route to those exams
can be liberating if nonconformist
I like being homeschooled why the
freedom I don't like a lot of rules
let's say but that freedom for all can
come at a cost to some local authorities
can only make informal checks on home
educators unless there are safeguarding
issues and they miss what happens to his
Shima's 'yes he was taken out of school
aged to 8 his father tried to home
educate him but when he fell ill Hashim
was left to fend for himself we
basically sat in our homes with the
books and expected to just get on with
it subjects which you know as you can
imagine for very kids was quite
sheltered at that point and didn't
really understand the value of education
it didn't work out so well so it just
ended up being we didn't really
accomplish my job doing he's pretty much
all Hashim is clearly naturally bright
but he's only now aged 23 taking his
maths GCSE have been already
accomplishing things at this point
rather than being
23 and just solve likely to get into
university maybe 27 28 at this point to
stop cases like ashame the government is
considering giving councils greater
oversight of home educators and starting
a compulsory register of all home ed
children it's a prospect many parents
feel is unnecessary and unfair the only
register in this country at the moment
for people is the sex offenders register
so do your parents have to be on a
register to be registered to her educate
the government admits the vast majority
of homemade parents do a good job but to
protect the few the many may face
tighter rules if they want to keep
educating the way they feel is best
Katerina Botox a Sky News